You are an important companion to me
[Music]
So
this is my feeling
A
flower with this name I was
actually making it little by little when you graduated, but I'm sorry to
post
that,
hurry up  It's a
bit rough because I finished it, isn't it? I
like this beach volleyball club. This is my place
where you gave me, so I
don't want you to
fall apart even if you say I'm selfish.
Thank you so much Akari It
's okay because we're friends Cole child
ana
[Music]
Calm down,
why don't we have a beach party here after the qualifying?
Then everyone is open and fair, so it's a match and a party
, I think that's the best, isn't it?
No matter what, I'll do my best to color the hall
Ah ah ah
[Music]